ladies and gentlemen Marvel wants us to forget
about that secret Invasion finale because we got
a Loki season two trailer today John how are you
good morning good morning I'm high key excited for
this how are you I'm doing well look who decided
to show up early and very I mean wow come on I'm
ready to love again wow here we are with koi so
we can talk for obnoxiously a long time ladies
and gentlemen leave a like and we gotta sponsored
a shout out today to to pay for this guy being
here this time let's swerve from the path of
our regular content to delve into a realm where
Shadow fights light mythical Champions become
the architects of their own destiny yes you've
called it rage Shadow Legends it's more than
just a name it's an invitation to a symphony
of battles that would make even a dragon trip in
the mystical expanse of Talaria Darkness looms
under the veil reign of the dark lord siroth
Only You Brave Summoner can conjure an alliance
of Champions to Vanquish this malevolent a world
teaming with dungeons formidable adversaries and
breathtaking Landscapes is yearning for a hero
from a legion of over 700 unique Champions across
diverse factions you can craft an army as unique
as a phoenix feather shape them into an unbeatable
force that will make even the stone golems envious
outfit them with potential artifacts imbue them
with Untold power and let them unleash their full
potential test your steel against other heroes in
the PVP Arena Battle the great leviathans of
the game World the send the clan rankings and
become the beacon of Glory in the gloaming The
Saga raid is ever evolving witness the terror
the new Phantom General akumori whose might
overshadows even the diarist of nightmares also
if the animated series raid called The Arbiter
Escape your gaze the complete 10 episodes of
way to an official raid Shadow Legends YouTube
channel sorry Ray to seize a sword of Destiny
and dive into the heart of Rage Shadow Legends to
some of my QR code or conjure up the link in the
description box to initiate your quest an epic
Champion Drake of the lizardmen faction along
with a horde of other Treasures awaits you let's
weave our Legends together so don't forget light
the way by hitting my link in the description box
or the QR code on screen and I'll see you in the
Twilight of the battlefield as the Arbiter
watches over us may you always find victory
at least I missed them obey hello
we have a little bit of a situation
we wanted to run by you movie again
wow time slipping wait is this spider-verse
glitch in real life looks awesome yeah can you
fix that no at least for the time slipping
the TVA I know but we just saw it happen
oh trippy pulled through time between the past
and the present hello what I saw is true Sylvie
there's nothing to stand between this world
and other destruction hey one way to find it
and girls behind them little good old-fashioned
leg work listen we have different styles you're
a man of action which is fine I take a more slow
deliberate cerebral approach it's really good buy
October 6 officially coming saniac it's up to us
that Sylvia works at McDonald's
hey Rafa
oh that was uh yeah yeah make the hard choice
yeah
always have been always moving
nice A little over the top don't
you think I thought it was spot on
man amount of Adventures are
going to be going on yeah
holy moly I've been lying if I said I did not have
nipple chills right now there's so much excitement
I haven't felt in so long yeah I feel like a
terrible thing of Marvel did not just air yes
good feelings without any asterisks or slight
tinge of negativity that I'm feeling even when
I'm out I'm in you know all right guys so as
much as the MCU has been a real up and down
up and down Journey with everything and you know
it's hard to find fault with anything that really
showed us here in this trailer it seems to be
carrying on what we love so much about the first
season of Loki without ruining what's to come
because you got so much off-kilter Adventures
that you're seeing on display here somebody
teases you know Ki Quan he's bringing that
a little Charming innocence to his character
and I'm like he's so he seems perfect for this
and almost I was like five seconds of him you
know what I mean and you've got these teases
of rivona rensslayer as well during the time
period of when we're gonna see Victor timely
which feels Comics accurate to John I had you
look up her name beforehand of what it altered
it was what was it Rebecca tormente don't try to
act like you just didn't look it up I looked it up
Rebecca terminate there just I was trying to get
you I can't remember if it was actually Rebecca
or not it's like a second like I looked it up a
second ago I should remember it's very early I
couldn't pull the name but yeah with the Rebecca
tormente of when Victor timely was introducing
these kinds of you know science mechanics to
the world and in the meantime he was also with
Rebecca torment so I feel like we're gonna see
the history there of how she became to be you
know the ravono ren Slayer that we see in Loki
season one who doesn't have a recollection of
these experiences at least that's what it seems
to be so yeah this is um this this is this is a
great trailer it's really hard to find fault with
anything right here I'm really the only thing I'm
really like keeping me apprehensive of just fully
surrendering to it is the fact that Marvel lately
has has been a very like uh Marvel Disney plus I
just don't mess this up yeah you know what I mean
um John which which what you got what you got
for us today yes yes aside from the general
apprehension of just the way things have been
going this is quite a dazzling trailer it's got
all the timey wimey stuff that you wanted up here
sprawling and jam-packed like we're going to have
a ton of Adventures that all seem yeah very
grave in terms of time and bouncing off the
Marvels you know with them doing the whole sort of
you know displacement teleportation thing and now
you've got Loki time slipping in the TVA and all
that stuff like it looks like it'll add further
layers of sci-fi to the already apparent on and
gallivanting across time and space and all that
stuff yeah man uh yeah and then like everybody
who's back looks great and I mean you get little
glimpses of like Eugene's in here and uh other
faces you know from uh the TVA I forget uh you
know the guard b129 or whatever is back like you
know I I really hope they can nail this because
yeah this looks absolutely dazzling yeah I mean
they even who's the guy who in the first step of
Casey is that his name oh that's the guy like that
that does the uh should we see the first yeah yeah
is it Casey yeah yeah you see Casey there and he
looks like he was imprisoned or something like
yeah he looks like he's in some Terry Gilliam
yeah he's like in time prison yeah yeah because
we weren't I wasn't sure whether or not were we
watching that's the great misleading part about
something with the Loki trailer is are is this
the TVA members from the first season are they
different TVA members are these TVA members carry
on is and they and they don't have a recollection
of are they variants they're exploring are they
meeting them for the first time or they won't
know what they have context because if I'm not
mistaken Loki season one they they one of the
reveals was that the TVA members they were uh a
variance right yeah yeah and they didn't know it
either they were like so you might have to meet
their original selves yes yeah so there's so many
ways to go with it and I feel like you know the
the amount of Adventures that we saw teased here
are going to give us more of what we've kind
of wanted from Loki season one even though I
thought that was great uh but some people did
feel a little bit let down by we didn't get to
go enough places and those people were wrong yeah
I I think this season looks like it could do the
thing that Marvel has needed to do for a very long
time which is unite all of the timeline elements
and make this Multiverse make sense they mapped
out the Multiverse quite a long time ago this
looks like not only it has introduce certain
Sony elements like the way the time slipping
looks which is directly pulled from into the
spider-verse but now as a live-action entity
but you get elements that could would tie in what
they're doing with Deadpool 3 because we know Miss
minutes is going to be a factor this morning
Miss minutes actually shared Allah the world of
this this trailer so we get certain elements that
are going to tie into what they're doing with the
fox implosion which we assume is going to be
Deadpool because the fox Universe to a point
this could also tie into what they do next with
Madame Webb because this comes out this October
Madam webs out in February I could see this tying
in what Sony does and like Fox does let's look at
that point this could be the thing that gets us
on track and their priority we've got to connect
to Matt guys you guys gotta look here I'ma look
here it's somewhere in the middle we get low-key
season two now this is uh Justin Benson Aaron
Morehead two directors I absolutely adore if
you haven't seen their other work they're absolute
Geniuses and they do so much really ominous dread
so we see a lot of fun here in hijinks but what
I love is those are our words ominous and dreads
well there's a lot of duplicitousness but I really
think there's gonna be a great uh a world where we
can have all the humor of having Owen Wilson and
Tom middlestone which is my favorite part of the
first season is just those great dialogue scenes
but with these guys directing it I'm excited to
see what Victor timely does uh behind the scenes
we see that shot of all the kangs coming at them
through the the scripture wall like we see a lot
of things that talk about this war so I'm really
excited to see what they bring specifically with
their tone to the Fun World of Loki which isn't
not dark and full of dread oh yeah they seem to
bring an actual like Macabre sense of humor to
the whole pitcher because there is a bit of a dark
Glee that it's kind of leaning into now that we're
looking at Sylvie in these imagery and you know
what it is actually what I just realized about
this whole thing is it seems to actually be a
little bit more like everything everywhere all at
once which is a little after towards it and there
are parts of Sylvie especially where it seems to
me that she does not have a recollection of things
seemingly yeah new haircut now McDonald's haircut
at McDonald's yeah but she seems lost like she's
at a place at a time in a lot of ways like this
is not what her identity belongs to just the looks
that she was giving and then she's slowly finding
herself maybe that's when Loki goes to like pull
her out of it in some way and I'm really not sure
Kang is able to control everyone else except Loki
maybe that's why he's time slipping I'm wondering
if everyone else has lost that context but he
couldn't trick Loki I also think it's really
interesting that at the end of this uh in the
comic books because of how popular Loki is you
may have noticed in the greater continuity Loki
was a villain and then Tom Hiddleston is just
so Charming so they actually in the comics changed
him from the broader definition of god of Mischief
to the god of stories because they wanted to
have him be less of a villain so at the end of
this trailer when he says I'm the god of Mischief
always have been always will be it seems to be
implying that he goes back to his villainous side
so I'm very curious uh as to what the manipulation
of Kang turns maloki into because he seems to be
the only one that has the full grasp of what's
going on yeah so John will throw it to you uh
Jonathan majors in the trailer do you think he's
innocent do you think he's guilty should he be in
the trailer let me get it all to you make it all
about that I have all these all about with that
John I think they should have put more Jonathan
Majors Clips in I think he should have been most
of the dialogue of this trailer I feel like that's
really the way to just meet things head-on just
to be like hey guys I was hoping we could just
step put this to the side for a little bit and
so then we could just talk about Kang being here
she's gonna be in here regardless since this was
already done before any of this stuff went down
we're gonna get it but you have to make it all
controversial that's my that's my goal you know
as Marvel needs to embrace the controversies in
all seriousness I was kind of surprised that they
actually did show even though it was just a clip
from Quantum me they just show his face he said a
line of dialogue yeah and it was a new one I still
still pretty much the same team it's the reveal
but now with dialogue yes it's the most acceptable
it was it was a questionable thing of like oh will
they show him well then like regardless of
whether or not you you believe he's innocent
or not right uh it's not even about that it well
it is about that I'm just saying that we're like
it's he's such a controversial figure at the
moment that I was surprised that we we did see him
but they wanted to give lots of people thumbnails
and then at the same time it would have been
um uh it would have been controversial yeah it's
a no it's a no-win situation I think this is about
as much as they could have done because everybody
who's paying attention knows he's in the show and
knows that they can't just go back and retool the
whole thing so I think yeah just confirming like
yeah he's gonna show up is about as much as you
need for a trailer like this yeah yeah and then
just letting the rest play on the Intrigue of the
mystery and the mechanics I think it also allows
the a certain element of like who is he for people
that don't follow all the nitty-gritty of like
you see Kang you see Victor timely it doesn't
quite connect those dots so there is like that
undercurrent of the Imperial Palpatine behind the
scenes which I think is smart to keep him that way
because we don't know how much he's gonna be in
the show we know he's the big bad but I like that
there's an undercurrent of like what's happening
throughout this trailer yeah that's the whole vibe
of it even with Mobius I'm not I'm unsure like the
way the the opening images go because this could
be the same Mobius yeah it could maybe not could
not be difficult but he's allowed to get haircuts
my only criticism no jet ski but but yeah I think
I don't think they would want to show us that in
the trailer season five I feel like Marvel
MCU trailers today would show us that but uh
part of the dynamic though that I think does have
a cool flip to it is it seems that Loki's more
leading the way yes on their Dynamics whereas
before obviously in the last season you know
Mobius was more of the knowledgeable one and more
leading the way for Loki to eventually find his
own identity and throughout the course of the
series but here it feels like Mobius is more of
that supporting role you know it feels like they
took him seriously at the very end of Loki season
one just by what we're seeing here is is you know
he seems to clearly be the one who knows how big
of a threat Kang is and also all these things
happening to the timeline being somewhat directly
responsible so maybe yeah they are just deferring
to his knowledge it's out in two months I'm so
excited I'm excited for it too my one concern um
oh yeah yeah my only concern that I really have
about it is the fact that they did change from
Kate wasn't Kate Heron yeah that is my one concern
which you told me about that change I didn't know
about it until recently and you know it just read
to me like oh a bit of a Scott Derrickson Doctor
Strange situation where the person who's very very
passionate about the thing they Helm now had to
leave and they brought in someone else yeah and
then sometimes that different direction that is
being mandated by Studio does not equate I don't
want my location to being yeah like a transitional
building block and and while these directors are
good uh you know I wasn't a big fan of the Moon
night finale ultimately who's to say if that was
really their fault or not you know I I S I said
I am a bit apprehensive only because of that and
again because of what the MCU has been like lately
where it could be such an up and down Journey
but Loki season one was pretty awesome and and
many consider it the best series out of the
Disney plus Library so hope episode six doesn't
end with just punching stuff let's see how it
goes guys what did you think about this trailer
leave your thoughts down below um be sure to
leave a like subscribe and hey we will um let's
chat with you all soon thank you for being here